[Music]
hi and welcome to today's lecture
again about attacking chess and we're
gonna see
one of my favorite games
ever
a victory by daniel dubov again
last i think that's the last
lecture we
ended with a victory by duboff so this
time he has a wide pieces against
another young talent
as vani who is a german player
and duboff played an amazing game
against the queen's gambit which has a
reputation of being a boring opening
but not always dubaf is well known to
find very creative ideas
against all openings history he played
that is a main line
actually
that i want to compare myself to dubai
for anything but the way attacked the
king side in the game as you will see
reminding bf reminded me a bit of
a game that
that that i won in 2011
with an idea that we had worked on with
uh we stopped
so i also played with
rock d1
gave away the c4 pawn played e4
and then started an attack on the on the
king side
to which my opponent didn't react very
well
take stakes
e5
knight d5
and now bishop h6 was very strong
takes knight g5
so i'm straightening mate on h7 taking
on g5 doesn't help
oh well that's what he did but
anyway there is no good move f5 i will
take on person and it's game over
i took
straightening mates on h7 again
f5 i took straightening mate on h7 once
again
rock f6
queen h8 and then next is rock h7 and my
opponent
resigned so he should have played better
earlier i don't remember what was the
biggest mistake
by black
but anyway that that was
that was you know this kind of ideas
like h4 to play e5 and g5 and so on that
was typical topology was trying that in
any kind of position so
sometimes it worked sometimes it did not
um
but against this in this kind of
position it does make sense okay what
duboff did is a bit different but it was
also an attack against the black king
which is uh which is slightly unusual he
castle long side
i mean usually against the queen's
compete people cast a show side
do both played queen c2 bishop a6
and sacrificed the c4 pawn
just like in the game i showed
knight g5
knight c6
a3 just preventing any knight before
so for example your h6 would be just a
blender because white would play h4
the white king would the backing would
just be even weaker and taking on g5
never would never be an option because
after hd5 there would be a huge attack
and there you can see some similarities
with the game i just showed which was by
the way against grandmaster van der veer
from belgium
well it might be dutch but the game was
played in belgium
um g6 was played
which is perhaps what my shop and my
what my opener should have done in the
game as well
and above played h4
so
here black played bishop d6 it seemed
quite natural to
exchange
a few pieces but you should have done it
in a different way
so i just i shouldn't mention that
people in the room see the moves
unfortunately because i cannot
we cannot hide them
but you on the stream don't see the
moves which is
better
but then
i think knight d5 would have been a
better move although after for example
knight d5 ed5
and simply something like bishop e2
and then at some points on knight h7 h5
black is also under
very huge pressure um
not knight h7 right away the attack
would be
a little bit too slow
their black would somehow escape
um
but i think 95 was
was a more consistent consistent move
black played bishop d6
here taking and playing h5 would be very
interesting
but do both choose a different a
different approach you just played g3
keeping the tension
not like changing any piece of course
bishop f takes f4 is very welcome just
just g pawn gtx f4
and the the black king is even more
open
since the g file has opened
and with g3 white is potentially
threatening some bishop g2
creating some problems on the long
diagonal
the so the black position is extremely
unpleasant and pleasant to play already
queen is 7
h5
e5 black needs to react in the center
you cannot just wait until it gets mated
it needs to react
here to both decided to take on g6
actually this was
this was good as well
it looked a little bit premature but in
fact it works for example knight h7
takes
and after pawn takes
here bishop g2 is very strong
for example takes
bishop c6 and there are many threats
uh for example let's imagine that black
just takes somewhere
there are there already stretch like
this which should be working takes takes
and rock h1
takes takes and you can't even try to
generate counter play
you will get
you will just lose everything
so
for example bishop c6 queen g7 defending
g6
and simply check
and now take and rock h1 winning the
queen again
okay this is a computer variation
i mean knight h7 here is
i mean to sacrifice a piece then take on
g6 and then not even capture the pawn on
g6 just play bishop g2 when your f4
bishop is hanging this is obviously a
computer variation
uh which is not very human
but i have to say that the game that you
have played is not very human i mean
my own game which i just showed was
quite human i mean it was it was a good
game but i did not find anything
completely unrealistic but what do buff
i mean the way you both played that game
as you will see is just uh
incredibly spectacular so you could as
well have found knight h7
um anyway he took on g6
a to g
it might look dangerous to open the h
file but at least he's avoiding knight h
knight takes h7 ideas
and now bishop g2
black took on f4
white took on c6 actually this was very
interesting as well there are huge
compensation there is huge compensation
for the piece
for example
let's say bishop b7 to defend the knight
knight d5
takes takes
now this this is a pin so we are
straightening mating one
and okay some something like this for
example
and then rock takes g6 is
a strat if knight e7 the bishop on b7 is
hanging white would be winning here
and it would be hard to find a better
move after gf4 for example queen d7
we're going to
eliminate the f6 knight which is the
best defender in the position
and for example next could be just f3
and quick and queen h2 and there is
a very strong mating attack
so it's difficult i mean gf4 would have
been strong as well but duboff just took
on c6
of course black can't just afford moving
the a8 rock and a low g takes f4 then
not only will be
under the same kind of mating attack as
we have seen before
but you won't even be a psap so that
would be a disaster black needs to
complicate the position
and take
either on g3 or e3
and here do both played king b1
just taking his time
rock 88 so if gf2 queen f2 the king the
queen is coming to h4
and the attack is gonna be
quicker
so king b1 is just uh
it's just perf it's just a prophetical
move
what is
i think the main point of it is that in
some variation
i mean for example pawn takes g3 can be
a strat followed by queen g2 and that
won't be quintex u3 check so this is a
simple prophylactic move prophylactical
move
black played rock 88
and above went f4
which in practice i think is a very
interesting move but is objectively not
the best
this was very strong
so now this is no longer a check
so for example knight e4
and if knight takes e4 queen h2 is very
strong
and it will be impossible i mean black
is going to get mated
if he tries to escape with his king
perhaps knight d5 right away or just
check and knight d5
capturing the queen and it's game over
and for example if bishop g3 preventing
queen h2 then again knight d4
bishop e4 and rock g1 is coming
and then a sacrifice on g6
black is just a pawn up in this position
well two pawns up but okay the position
is just a disaster
so i think fg3 was
simpler
duboff choose f4 instead which in a way
is very logical just uh
i mean just taking all the space
even on the king side but the difference
is that it does not written queen h2
um
but anyway
i mean
black could have defined it there as you
will see but in practice i would i mean
objectively speaking f4
is not a good move but in practice i
would almost give it an
exclamation exclamation mark because the
black difference is extremely difficult
black found the correct move bishop c8
this would be
met with knight d5
again trading this very important knight
and straightening checkmate here because
of the pin
and for example that would be
bishop f7 then rock h7 check
and game over
black found this great move bishop c8 in
order to be able to defend with bishop
f5 in many positions
duboff simply played rogue de1
actually it's not a piece down here it's
just two pounds the pawn on g3 is likely
to fall
so white can afford taking his time
king g7
now white will have to hurry up because
rock h8 is coming
knight d5
95 check
very important
so that black is not in time to play
rocket h8
king g8
and now
the most beautiful part of the game
starts rock takes f7
if bishop takes d5 which looks looks
very natural so written in quintex g6
mate then bishop f5
e4
optically it looks completely winning
for white but actually black is just
escaping here
because all of the white pieces are
hanging you come back on f5 because of
queen e1
and for example
that would be
i mean that is for example the computer
line
now the rokin f7 is hanging
takes
and now the engine finds rock takes d4
some incredible line
just takes
and with such reduced material
the engine considers that black is even
better actually there is no mate and
there are three pawns for the exchange
including the g3 pawn which
used to be a weakness but is now a very
stronger set in the black position
but duboff
i don't know if he calculated
everything incredibly well or if he just
had the right the correct feeling that
you should not just play bishop takes d5
he played rock f7
black two can have seven which seems
like
the only move you want to say what else
and actually it's incredible that here
in order to save the game black should
check
and they then take on f7
and i'm going to show the difference
later
and because right now it is impossible
to understand
of course any human including carlson
anyone here would play rock f7
bishop
quite a g6 sorry king f8
if frog g7 and bishop d5 with check
would be
a very strong attack
actually i could i could show this for
example this is a nice line
check
takes and mate
king f8
now everything is pretty forced
if kj is back now bishop takes d5 is
completely winning
so rogue g7
bishop d5 street and queen h8
actually here black had one last
chance to save the game but you should
find something incredible he played king
e8 which again any human would play
and in fact he had to play bishop f5
check and then king e8
that's
that is something incredible but the
difference is
i mean again we're going to
see the difference with the game
let's first let's have a look at the
game
kg8
queen h5
king d7 if king f8 it's queen h8
queen h3
k8
actually the difference now with bishop
f5 is quite easy to explain if the
bishop was on f5
there would be no queen h3
so that one is much easier to explain
than than knight history check which i
will explain later
so i can show the lights after bishop f5
and king e8
now queen h5 check doesn't make any
sense because not only can there would
be king d7 but probably also bishop g6
so for example a sample line could go
bishop c6 check so that the king does
not escape
bishop d7
check
check and actually
white does not have more than a draw
here
you can also
white can also try to take and suck the
rock
and here for example a good defense for
black would be queen e3
just so that when white takes on g7
black has a perpetual check
these are the some symbol lines
but bishop f5 check was necessary after
k8 black is lost
check
so do both repeated moves once then
played bishop e6
the king has to go to c6 that's also i
mean this bishop b6 is again one
difference
i mean once a move that would not happen
if the black bishop was on f5
queen f3 jack
the king has to go to b5
bishop takes c4
if black takes on c4 gets mated check
if king d3 or king b3 is queen c2 mate
so he needs to play here
check
check
check and then
roxy one made
so in the game black played king a5
queen d5
bishop c5
b4
can you know now guess why knight c3
check was necessary
because here the pawn would be on c3 and
there would not there would not there
would be no b4 check and there would be
no checkmate
this is
so now let's get back to knight c3 check
if white plays the same way
then there is no b4 and it's the end of
the attack
of course it was barely
i mean it was
i would say almost i would say
impossible to calculate
i mean to understand said i mean
to play knight is three check you you
need
you need to calculate all this otherwise
there is no point playing 93.
um i don't think any humanity would do
though you might have the right feeling
that anyway the bishop would come to d5
and that the white king is a little bit
weaker with the b bone on c3
but that would really be a matter of
luck i mean it's like playing rule
already you know
should i play knight c3 should i include
it or not
is a pawn better on b2 or c3 i mean it's
impossible to
guess right now
so anyway in the game
the king went to a5
now c5 b4
um
will be a short mate
as well
just similar to the game
um
so i think check
and now should white play like in the
game or should we start with
this feels like a mate in many ways
perhaps this simply if check just e4
i mean row k1 is coming this feels like
a mate queen b5 is king if king takes b4
that has to be a mate
but i played bishop c5 which is a little
bit more
challenging as at least the white queen
is
hanging but before check
and now not queen c6
because after king takes a3 there will
be no mate but queen g2 is a very
precise move
if black takes on a3
then that's a simple mate
bishop takes b4
what else queen c2 check was coming so
bishop takes b4 is the only way
to free the a5 square for the king so
now quincy took a5 and there is no mate
anymore
and now queen c6 check
king takes a3
and the big difference i mean because
white could have got the same position i
mean otherwise played queen c6 you would
get the same position
without bishop takes before and cladded
but it actually favors
white a lot
to include these moves because here
duboff has a very nice
win
i mean you guys watching the streaming
and
oh you don't see the moves here either
okay very good so why to play and win
then
i fixed it you fixed it yeah
i mean many times i could have tried i
could have asked to
find find the next move for white but i
thought
i saw the moves are appearing so
you know
i'm not sure you straightened very much
because my bishop would cover the check
on if on a5 so i could go bishop a5 or i
could be greedy and even take take the
rock on e1
because queen a7 bishop a5
and that's it
so it feels like a mate but there is
actually only one winning move here
so
everyone in the chat is proposing rocky
2 as well
but actually rocky 2 is a mistake
because of bishop d2
just above just preventing rock a2 and
next is queen before check and suddenly
black is having a lot of counter play
check and the bishop might come into
into the action
so rocky 2 is actually not winning
what was your other idea
you said e4 yeah um
probably well actually bishop takes e1
after e4
then that
well i mean
i was going to say that that's many
pieces but
black is already a rock up so one rock
or two rocks
uh doesn't matter if you don't mate
you just lose the game
so queen g2 is being proposed in the
chat but then i think bishop d2 again
same thing and if queen takes the two
then queen b4 check trading queens
so one the correct answer was given in
the chat
um bishop b5
what if i just take the rock
queen c1
that could be a checkmate
bishop b5 maybe
bishop c5
yeah because if we shop take c1 then
queen c1 and queen c4 and queen a4
bishop c4 bishop b5 actually maybe
bishop d2 again
just stopping any check
and queen before is coming
so rock d1 is being proposed but i think
again
black has at least bishop d2 in order to
play queen before jack
so that's already moved 35
duba found the first 35 moves of this
masterpiece you only have to find
the 36 move
he did 97 of the job for you
so i got many answers in the chat but
only one
only one is correct
knight e4 bishop f5
correct
as i was wondering if i should say it
because
somebody just asked not to give the
answer but okay
now it was given and two percent in the
chat found it as well
bishop b3
the bishop is untouchable because of
check and mate
white is written in
queen a4 8
and if black wants to prevent it with b5
or with bishop d7 like in the game
then check
you force black to take and then
you mate
and this is how the game finished
um black even allowed checkmate over the
over the board which which generally is
a sign of respect
at this at such a high level when you
allow your opponent to checkmate you
when mate is clearly coming on the next
move it generally it is generally a way
to say it to say okay well done
that is that is really one of my my
favorite games of
all times actually dubaf has played many
masterpieces but
i
this is one of my favorites so what
should we remember for from that game
um
i mean first of all the way he
just ignore the c4 pawn
to start an attack on the on the king
side
uh that is interesting because black is
having problems to open the position if
i mean b5 b4 is just uh slow i mean h5
knight h7 is coming very quickly
but then the way the way duba funded
complications was
just amazing of course you here we saw
that knight h7 was possible but that was
really tough
uh this was more human
this is a highly interesting move as
well um
because i would say that here it does
not require
such a precise calculation you just take
back on f4
your threatened to
take the piece back on c6
and if black plays basically any move to
defend the knight then knight d5 for
knight e4 is coming you eliminate the
knight
and there is a huge attack the only way
for black to stop the attack would be to
go king king g7 and rock h8 but he's
never in time for that because knight d5
on it4 is coming you're going to trade
the defender and then the
the rock is coming to h7 and it's
and it's over
then this can be one move i mean
generally when you launch such a furious
attack
you're looking for extremely concrete
moves you
you you want to checkmate your opponent
immediately you want to prove that your
attack is a success
and it is not easy to play such a move
like king b1 in such a tense position
f4 was very human and i was also
although this was stronger
i don't think that duba i think i don't
probably do buffs out that both moves
are very good
i mean because f4
black is basically holding by
miracle
i think he simply saw that was
even stronger than fg3
and then this precise calculation this
knight is three check
with this amazing difference that 10
moves later there won't be b4 check
again this which is which is slightly
easier to find the nicest three check
but still very inhuman
and then the end of the game is just a
masterpiece
unfortunately well i mean
unfortunately he played i don't know
could he play could he play queen h1 in
alpha zero style i mean you know that
alpha zero is
has this reputation of playing kh queen
h1 in many positions
i i guess it works as well i don't see
i don't see a big difference
queen h1 with the same idea of taking
i don't think there is a difference we
can
we can double check with
an engine but i think it's basically the
same
yeah it's the same king a5 queen d5 yeah
okay you can see after a few seconds
the engine says it's a mate i don't
think g2 changes anything
at first it says so but it's also going
to the evaluation is also going to go up
oh actually
then i would blame doom up duba from
that because if you have a chance to
play queen h1 check you should play it i
think
but okay
bishop c4 and what a precise calculation
till the end queen g2
provoking bishop b4 and then queen c6
and this final blow
yes i said alpha zero i don't know sorry
if i mispronounced it or something
just answering the chat
uh so okay that was that's
as i said one of my favorite games ever
perhaps my favorite game ever
so
we have a bit of time left
let's see that game
so that's a game between gashimav and
lalit
which was played in 2007
so as you know geshimov
unfortunately passed away
a few years later
although he was still young and one of
the best players in the world
and lalitch
is a
well ladies
reputed i mean he's made
his reputation is that he's making a
draw against anyone
doesn't matter from 1900 to 2700 is just
making draws all the time
that's why his rating is dropping
because he spring open tournament and
he's always proposing draws to everyone
but
it is not very often that he loses and
gashimav really
made it in brilliant
fashion in that game so that was a solid
petrov
which
is i think
an opening that fits that each style
a very solid opening this line with
knight is three which looks very which
looks symmetrical it doesn't look much
but actually it is highly interesting
for white
especially after a short castle that was
played in the game because after h3
then black
doesn't know what to do with his c8
bishop
actually bishop g4 is supposed to be
more precise
still it is not entirely easy you play
like this
bishop to f4 something like that but
well you know you go rookie e3 then you
try to get the e5
a little bit off there is a little bit
of pressure for white but bishop g4 is
normally
i mean bishop g4 should be close to
equality but after h3 already it's not
so easy to play as white as black
h6 was played
rocky one
bishop d6
knight e5
so the white queen is ready to jump to
i mean the white queen is heading to h5
if any capture on e5 then pawn takes and
then maybe we'll we will advance the f
pawn or maybe queen h5 maybe some
sacrifice on h6
black has to be careful queen h5 is a
very
strong strat here then bishop h6 could
really happen so black played queen h4
which is a good move
rock b1 that's a typical move
because it forces black to take a dece
to make a decision
you cannot move a c8 bishop you cannot
play rogue b8 because of knight takes c6
you cannot play b6 because of knight xc6
as well
if he goes knight a5 then this knight is
a bit out of play
so it it doesn't look very streaming but
that's a very clever move
black 2 can play bishop c5
queen f3 bishop b6 was played
d5 is not hanging because of queen takes
f2
bishop is three
takes takes bishop b6 was played
and here you might think that black has
i mean
if you remove queens from the position
black is just slightly better you have
double pawns on the c file
this is just a perfect position for
black but actually this move bishop e6
is a huge blender
you should black should have played c5
sacrificed
the d-pawn
and there would be a bit of compensation
here although
okay this is an extra pound for white
but a2 is uh pretty weak
that their black would have
very reasonable chances something like
this to prevent f4
play rock e8
i mean black is a pawn down but he has a
perfect position besides this
so you would have chances to save the
game
but well
bishop b6 is a very human reaction just
protecting the d5 pawn
and now rule b1 rb1 proves even more
clever
rock f4 rock b4 excuse me
queen e7 and rocket f4
so all of the white pieces are heading
to the
king side
black is white is trying to check mates
and here black played c5 which is now
a big another mistake
it is too slow you will see why in the
game instead black should have played
rock fd8 trying to make room for his
king to run away at some point
so how did gashima punish c5 can you
guess the move for white here
yes rock f6
just paralyzing black completely
and
now it becomes obvious why the f8 rock
should have been played because
if at some point you want to take on f6
you need the king to be able to run away
so c5 was too slow
after rock f6
um laleach played rock fd8
trying to make
well now he wants to run away with his
king but it's too late queen h5
the rock is still untouchable queen
attacks h6 and then rogue d3 that will
be a mate
king f8 black runs away
rock g3
again the rock is untouchable
queen takes h6 and bishop b5 check
preventing king d7 and then rock g8 is
next and game over
so black played c4
trying to get
i mean trying to limit the white bishop
and also preventing any bishop b5 check
and now can you find how gashimov
finished up the game
bishop h7
i wouldn't call it a bad move
definitely because
i don't see what black would do next but
gashima found something even stronger
pretty sure bishop h7 is winning as well
it's returning rock g7 preventing gf6
so all of the white pieces it is
difficult to imagine
horror better
how you could improve any of the white
pieces but if you don't if you can't
concretize the attack then it would
suddenly collapse because
your rock and f6 is hanging your bishop
is hanging
although it's true that that bishop h7
is a good is a simple solution
but what can be stronger than that
something much more direct
it was found in the chat several times
so in the chat you many of you found the
right move
but then after c takes d3 what do you
play
since the chat tried to give me
at least a two moves variation
actually three moves if possible
so here was played
rock g7
bishop h7 was a good move as well i i do
confirm
then the best try for black would be
queen h3 so that if you suck on g7 or h6
there will be queen t1 check
intermediary to defend h6
but here rock takes e6 will be winning
and then you will have a check and queen
f7 mate so bishop h7 was very strong as
well
but rock g7 is even stronger
if king g7 is pretty easy you just check
check and mate
but after
pontex d3
trying to escape with the king
i mean king e8 is possible but
then rock g7 is just a free pawn you go
bishop f5 or whatever not only you have
the attack but you have extra materials
so the only challenging move is state
xd3 and now how does white
finish his attack
sorry i'm sorry can you repeat that if
king here is what happened
i mean king e8 the thing is that white
has an extra opponent so
any move actually i mean bishop g6 or
bishop f5
white would have a strong attack and an
extra pound so
this is not challenging it's not like
it's running into mate in two
but the only way to challenge rock take
g7 when the matter i'm here the material
is sequel this is not like dubaf game
when black was had an extra rock all the
time
here if black doesn't take something
it's just a pawn down
so it needs this is the only challenging
move
and the way to punish it is
you should do anything to prevent king
e8
so here you check
force the king back to g8
and after rock h6 there is no defense
against rock hate and queen h6
if king g7 then rock h7 check first
and then rock h8 queen h6
can you go back to what happened
e8 instead of taking the bishop well the
thing is as i said
white we just have an extra pawn here so
let's say i go for example here
but i mean even if i just i mean of
course
any
attacking move is just better because
the f7 pawn is gonna fall but even if i
even if i just go bishop f1 let's say
it's an extra pawn for white
so after rock g7 the only way to
challenge white is to take some material
if you run away even even if that works
even
i mean
even if k8 would not
would not run into bishop g6 or bishop
f5 then it would just be a huge extra
point for white h6 would also fall so
that would be soon two extra pounds you
need to take the material otherwise you
better resign
but rock g8 check is the point takes
rook h6
with a forced checkmate so it's
quite amazing from from a position that
looked
pretty boring in just a few moves
the rock came from b1 to f6 and that was
basically over
see how quickly that went
one two
three
four
five just uh
only attacking moves
and it went incredibly incredibly
quickly from a position that looked very
solid for black
this plan of bringing the rock to f6 was
just a killer
so here we are for today
so that was gashima flalich played in
in france in 2007
one of gashimov brilliances
he played many a ptd
you could not play more
because he was a very strong attacking
player as well
thanks everyone for watching
thank you for being here
in the classroom
thank you for
all your comments and answers and
questions in the chat
and
see you
tomorrow or thursday no see you on
saturday tomorrow so the schedule's
gonna get real weird for streaming okay
i got
according to my schedule i think uh it's
thursday but uh maybe
maybe caleb is gonna tell me that
everything changes i don't know
it'll it'll probably be just for the
house not streaming because we'll be
live with the tournament yeah
okay
okay i hope you enjoyed the game
[Music]
the 2022 chess season is off and running
join us in april for the first american
cup
world-class chess masters will gather in
the chess capital of america st louis
missouri to compete in a do or die
struggle for a combined purse of 300 000
we will cover all the action live from
april 20th through april 29th
tune in for the best game in chess
streaming live
for more information visit
uschestchamps.com
[Music]
[Music]
so
you